you were quite taken by the tragedy of
this for tatal the tragedy of this for
France I mean it's extraordinarily sad
news Kristoff is a wonderful guy
engaging smart always willing to mix it
up uh we were talking earlier about
what's happening all oil prices he's
consistently believed they are going
higher that's part of why he's been AGG
he was so aggressive and successful in
building up resources for the company
but but just a neat guy but the neat guy
of it to me was that the US oil
companies to an extent are more reserved
more measured more academic where he's
on a jet going around trying to find the
next gajillion barrels and this is a
complicated one in Russia because of the
geopolitical situation there but he was
forward leaning on a lot of different
things another space where he was
outspoken was on climate change he was
there trying to build up on oil but also
talking about how we had to tackle
climate uh a sort of Frank sentiment you
don't hear so much from us Executives is
that even possible though I've always
wondered about this you know watching
BP's advertising on clim change is it
possible to run a company that extracts
natural resources and also figure out a
way to make investments on climate
change has Oil Company done that I think
it is look they're not going to Le to
charge on climate change but they can uh
help us understand how to transition
from cold to gas uh they can make it
clear that it's compatible to cut our
consumption even as Western companies
invest more in production